yin and yang Fire and Ice every force in
life has its opposite and in the world
of csgo there are no two forces more
important than patience and aggression
because it takes time to be ready
they're good
what is this oh my God
that's ridiculous to Peak or not to Peak
to Suka blyat Rush be my friends or run
a so-called default these questions have
been at the Forefront of Counter-Strike
philosophy since 1.6 and yet as with all
opposites this tension isn't just
complementary it's the key to success
and now Texas is put into action and
he's boosted up they have no idea he can
hold the trigger he can just chill he's
gonna get both kills for free and they
think the bomb set is clear Texas has
them all pulled and there it is
and at one point in time there were no
two players that contrasted one another
more than a certain CIS Duo by now there
is a very good chance that you've at
least heard of Jane since in addition to
being a major winner his Infamous saves
have been memed upon by the community
for quite some time 10 seconds a plant
Department aim is alone coming in from a
short position tarot just needs to hide
I want to talk to force him forward
but he's going to be on the angle one
second and there is the win by timeout
so from tarik's position there is a
flashbang that you can throw which goes
behind the palm tree but today we are
going to be focusing on the man who was
once the fury to James
frugality I am of course talking about
Marx yakindar galinski's the Latvian
Leviathan who has become infamous in the
server for two things aim and aggression
bombs in transition between both
websites here what a peak that was a
York this is gonna be so difficult to
get past oh and a leash goes down as he
jumps
that is so punishing not another one
actual damage from your Kinder into Grim
now they're running on fumes
yeah they get out middle again they
still challenge at Rambo once more to
the advantage of VP don't mess with the
akindar at ramp and during the time when
the two still played together it was
abundantly clear just how contrasting
their approach to CS go was you see in
the moments where James liked to save
yakindar preferred to strike it's the
old Jam come on Jim you gotta bring it
to the site your team are already here
taking fights come on you got to get the
bomb over here with 20 seconds left your
Kindle's gonna have to try and get a
kill but what what's happening right now
you can't know it's going to do
everything and it's James just not going
for it
but he can't escape Yuri takes him down
and he Kinder's watching shortly to have
a smoke for it like you said your Kindle
could wrap them here if he hits a good
timing they've all gone the other way
around he's alone but he's got them
behind he's got a spray thinks they're
monster both on the site he's seen them
now bomb dropped farmer
however right as the Duo's differences
found a way to coexist they were all but
forced to part ways and where one found
success the other found himself tasked
with saving a struggling region but how
exactly did yakindar develop his
signature aggression did he somehow help
his former team win a major just months
after his departure and ultimately does
yakindar have what it takes to be the
hero na so desperately needs the uproots
this round you kind knows that they're
in dark but it's oh
very quickly before we get into today's
offbeat I just wanted to remind you all
that we have merch head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out the Sea
of super cool hoodies and t-shirts that
we have in tons of different colors
they're super comfortable I wear them
all the time buy us aside they're great
check them out before we get into North
America's Lord and Savior Marx I just
wanted to make a note that to avoid
confusion I will be referring to the VP
Outsiders roster as just Outsiders
instead of jumping back and forth cool
cool all right so since 2019 the Cs go
community at large has been at the mercy
of a recurring and somewhat maddening
phenomenon known as Jame time you see
James is the Opera and igl for CIS
Powerhouse Outsiders and well as it
turns out he really really likes his off
so much so that he has a propensity for
saving it whenever the odds seem even
remotely out of his favor maybe not um
it's James all right never mind yep my
time's done thank you James another uh
great opportunity to the awp well done
and uh Jane of uh meme Fame everyone are
they just trying to see if they can pull
the rotations the bomb eventually is
going to be going out towards that Bay
Side so much time yeah they're just
saving it I guess because they weren't
able to find a frag no mistakes really
got pulled in the rotations they just
hold on to their weapons but today's
subject has never been called boring
that's because yakindar isn't isn't your
stoic to the point of being dull CIS
Counter-Strike Pro he is a balls to the
wall Ferrari peaking entry Fragger who's
been able to find success in spite of
his former roster's infamous passivity
okay Nikita just found Perfecto and
suddenly we're in trouble Street
Electronics
Stands Tall for virus Pro it's a great
weapon to have on your team I'm not
talking about the gun I'm talking about
this individual on your screen right
here but to understand how he went from
being one of the cis's greatest talents
to team liquid's last hope we need to
find out where the hell this Beautiful
Bastard came from yakindar hails from
Latvia plays on 69 because he's a giga
Chad and being that he was born in 1999
is also a certified Zoomer which may or
may not explain his playstyle and unlike
most other Pros around his age
yakindar's First Love wasn't 24 hour
dust 2 servers it was Taekwondo at first
I was like no I don't want to go mom you
know and everything like that but then
afterwards when I actually started
when I became older right because I
started when I was like 12 or 11 when I
was like 14 15 I actually enjoyed it
because I was going to a lot of
tournaments I was traveling the world
already that like back then and I think
it strengthened me as uh strengthened me
as a individual and my like maybe
psychology and at the time he played a
lot of video games specifically League
of Legends and of course CS go after he
hit Global Elite in CS go A Whole New
World of opportunities opened up before
him back then you Kinder mostly
participated in local land tournaments
but after he joined the once legendary
1.6 org Pro 100 in 2018
yakindar truly started to turn heads
definitely there's been no round where
we were sat here scratching our heads
going what the hell were they oh not
again I smoke the entire time someone
got four kills from it what the hell is
Heck in there doing they were back to
back he's got the aid Get Wrecked yucky
won several qualifiers and C tier events
on that team and he looked so good
individually that heading into the
online era Outsiders picked it up
Outsiders needed well a kick in the
pants and yakindar looked like just the
man to revitalize their stagnant
playstyle it was a perfect match the
rise of this so-called onlineers came in
full force towards the end of 2020 and
Outsiders were a team to be reckoned
with winning Flashpoint 2 and the dream
hack December open 14 seconds of plot in
his bum the cavalry's on the way looking
to trample on OD this could be the last
round of Trades continue that bomb has
to get planted though mantu is still
going for the fries five seconds it's
over it's all over unless Buster can be
found running away to Victory 500k
perverters bro they take Flashpoint too
they've done it James the rotation works
out James this time Lance the shot that
they needed he even got kicker holding
the line top mid right now
and that's just there two members of
Saul left and uterus he's gonna go down
as well and that's BP taking it and by
the time they won CS Summit 7 in January
yakindar's team cracked the HL tv top
five but for all intents and purposes
when it comes to Outsiders 2021 was
yakindar's year you Kinder wants to
change that
oh and he wins it out against the orb no
less his moves So Graceful and his shots
so pinpoint perfect they're already up
close towards the boxes Duprees firing
off your kind has dropped the bomb and
he's managing to stall out Dupree's
fight
full femuses and an org on the other
side and there's the opening yakinda I
have not seen a player entry frag mid
like this kid now you might be wondering
just
how aggressive is your Kindle
I'm glad you asked a good way to measure
aggression is how often a player gets
around opening kill and according to
hltv in 2021 yakindar was second only to
the Brazilian madman art when it came to
that stat so yeah he is a world-class W
Warrior hell even the aggro king himself
has put respect on yakindar's name there
was a guest player
if I would not say myself I would say
yeah I guess is the most Quest player
that's not an opera as well it's very
rare to find the game usually the guest
players are outputs as well but the
thing about your camera is that he
recognizes that effective aggression is
n't just about predictably pushing
smokes and wildly peaking Corners
sometimes it can all come down to good
positioning E2 though they could have
bought AKs but they want the SMGs for
the fast play your Kindle shot took down
quad kill on the ramp of course what
makes this also mind-boggling is that of
all the rosters he could have ended up
on this dude ended up on James while the
two are clearly Polar Opposites yakindor
has said repeatedly that he deeply
respects James approach to CS go and
that it gave him the freedom to play as
wildly as he wants when you have me for
example I have my own Ambitions and I'm
willing to do some some things and if
the team doesn't allow allow me to do it
then it's gonna be bad but since James
really nice and smart in-game leader he
sets up the system of our game really
perfectly together you Kinder and James
coexistence created this beautiful
ballistic tension between careful
systematic caution and unpredictable in
your face chaos that quickly is up he's
gonna go through this yeah he's taken
such a huge amount of space and this
passive hold
there is no one home fallen's already
gone Grim doesn't have a chance and just
like that the restaurant be twiddling
their thumbs now that's not to say that
things were perfect for Outsiders
although there were plenty of things to
be proud of the roster was still looking
for that big win and it didn't come in
2021 that being said there were still
tons of Promise heading into the new
year Outsiders were named the seventh
best team of the year and most
importantly yakindar was placed eighth
on the hltv top 20 list yakindar was the
real deal and his team was one to watch
he's gonna be first point of contact
does he know he does Malta to flush him
out he's going to be forced out of his
position but the smoke comes in from his
teammate and it is going to kicker with
a double and art left alone in a 1v3
there's nothing you can do Dinko and
that is gonna be it and furnace Pro take
the championship here the install
Challenger 48 they're able to take them
down but that's where his story with
James because the Russian invasion of
Ukraine flipped the world of csgo on its
head and yakindar found himself between
a rock and a hard place since he wasn't
Russian himself and happened to be
fluent in English yakindar had immediate
opportunities to play with International
rosters that his teammates likely
wouldn't have had a spot on he had to
make the decision to put his future
first by July yakinder got picked up by
North America's Flagship CS go org a
roster and region in desperate need of a
spiritual awakening and while there were
the expected Growing Pains yakindar's
Firepower was felt almost immediately so
he's being as smart as he can he he has
to close the distance he knows he has to
get to the diffuser that's the bigger
issue he's got to show up but does he
have the time he's gonna go away oh my
God he's just barely just barely gets
there in time you Kinder playing a
divider with that deagle
oh he gets the head shot needs more he's
got another mess oh
utility damage Breeze comes in with a
nice clean head shot and you Kinder okay
that's four the ace oh my God he's back
but while North America rejoiced and
heralded yakindara as the second coming
something miraculous happened with his
former roster the loss of yakindar on
Outsiders was devastating to say the
least but in his absence the roster
picked up two Young Guns they had nutty
aim and fierce aggression that more than
made up for their lack of experience
just like yakindar once had and while
liquid faltered at the Rio major
yakindar's old teammates found a rhythm
so Flawless it led to one of the most
convincing wins in major history United
as Outsiders
and ground your champions of I am Rio
2022.
now in the aftermath yakindar
congratulated his old but as an added
consolation I don't think it's a stretch
to say that Yaki played some very small
part in that Victory without yakindar's
past influence they never would have
first discovered that X Factor James big
brain and pensive playstyle needed that
opposing Force to keep him in check now
your Kinder shouldn't be credited for
Outsider success and definitely has his
work cut out form on liquid but if any
player can restore this org and region
to its former glory
it's this guy liquid is objectively a
much better team now than they were
before the latvian's arrival and the
numbers don't lie this kid is one of the
most menacing fraggers in the world
right now it also finally feels like
liquid is finding consistency and
confidence in the clutch something
they've lacked for quite some time kaiwu
tries to move back in close
feels like you can't set a foot wrong
just holds the angle and they come to
HIM Tears through the liquid ranks and
OC finished off to close three in the
round from OC liquid have got to finish
what he started and it's iwu the man to
beat
chases him down trying to take it over
the line trying to win this
a nap with that swing liquid completed
come back 12 rounds in a row of 13 to
half only one question remains can
liquid wholeheartedly adopt the
philosophy of throwing caution to the
wind and truly holding down that WP
because one thing is for certain
yakindar isn't changing anything about
his playstyle for anyone anytime soon
and by God he shouldn't have to Carrigan
in a too shabier position looks to miss
right dead from a left Nitro and OC
making it down to 40 and they've done it
let's go back into this and FaZe go home
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
[Music]